die nächst wie gesagt feiern wir
geburtstag max kommt mich besuchen und
dabei wahrscheinlich ein paar videos
machen oder so möchte man wieder auf
festen geburtstags blog
flowers es geht sondern willkommen zu
einem spielmodus den wir lange nicht
mehr gesehen haben auf diesem januar und
zwar den ender gamespot würde ich mal
sagen immer noch ein spielmodus die ich
sehr mag dem er immer noch gut gefällt
und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht die
haben wir so lange nicht mehr gesehen
der muss einfach wieder gebracht wenn
ihr den letzten auch wieder beim joggen
gesehen hektar wald mpeg damals habe ich
gern gesehen hat mir geht auch bei durch
kleiner peter sg du kleiner pisser hab
ich zu mir selbst gesagt du kleiner
pisser stand vom spiegel sagst du
kleiner pisser ist immer wieder ändern
games und dann haben wir es einfach
gesagt warum ich habe es gesagt ihr
wisst ich wünsche zufrieden und da unten
gut zu wissen dass sie einfach nichts
verändert hat es sind immer noch die
gleichen [ __ ] die einem jedes mal
das holz klauen wollen
ok sorry leute ich meinte [ __ ]
wisst schon die söhne von uhren die
ja halt söhne von uran nicht dem an
jeder schon mal erfahrung mit söhne von
uhren gemacht da ist jetzt rolex oder
nur festina oh gott bitte nicht alter
hat jetzt kurz paranoia das irgendwie
die schutzzeit endet bevor ich da auf
schlager einen hellen dicken falschen
bekommen unten haben wir ein
vollsortiment zeigt sich zeitig kollege
zeig dich
okay das ist ein richtiger richtiger
richtige escape einfach vollkommen
unüberlegt war drauf gedroppt vision ist
ein richtiger bastard manchmal frage ich
mich selbst was ich da mache wir haben
leider auch noch überhaupt keine rüstung
und food mäßig ist jetzt auch nicht so
gut bestellt um uns ne yo yo 17 blöcke
jiji ich mache meinen kleinen abgegangen
darum müssen schicken werden aber leider
kein feuerzeug könnte es nicht anbrennen
das heißt gibt heute kein kentucky fried
chicken sondern nur kentucky schicken
einfach es ist einfach nicht frei man
halt einfach froh und kentucky forscher
auch nicht machen
auch mensch das ist doch nix ihr ohne
ohne freiheit macht das alles keinen
spaß so ein rohes münchen ist doch
keiner
das war doch kein spaß das heißt da
nicht
lolita schöne boden gebracht dessen die
besten momente des tages wenn ich immer
wieder neues boden bei uns zwar leute
was habe ich für euch jetzt für europa
kommt vergessen ich wollte dem thema
entsprechend und zwar meinen geburtstag
ja ich habe demnächst geburtstag anfang
oktober in wenigen wenigen tagen
ich sag's einfach am vierten geburtstag
besonders hakt und ich werd 19
das dürften auch manche von euch wissen
vielleicht nicht vielleicht doch keine
ahnung wie gut ihr gestellt wird soll ja
ein schweinegeld schwenker gejammer von
p&g schaaf noch mehr schwein und braucht
dringend einen speck
schwein kommen ja ja ich werde okay wird
gepostet und schäfer nach unten und
kühler rechtsklick untersteht direkt
eine kiste nicht gereift sozusagen
direkt rein
und hier sehen wir die klassische baum
kuh jetzt versucht hat sich als normale
bodencrew auszugeben was mir natürlich
aufgefallen ist
diese hinterlistige täuschungsversuch
die hier war der ganz normale bodencrew
und ja ich werde 19 jahre alt das wohl
auch ein känguru ja ich war 19 jahre alt
und dafür kommt wirklich besuch auf dem
max ok ok was war das bitte für mich
okay alles klar
das war der ich habe irgendwie die mega
kasse keine ahnung was um mich herum
bewegt beginn meiner nähe
du kriegst todes hit ohne was machen zu
können variante das war die supertolle
varianten erste map zu ende
okay sind tot wir sind auf den freitod
wir haben noch ein halbes jahrzehnt
halbes herz immer wieder gefordert
werden können bitte mal gepostet werden
sind gleich dauern
wir sind vielleicht laufe ich kann auch
nicht sagen weil ich oh ja und er bei
chelsea
und wir werden ihm die tauschte im ernst
im ernst alter das kann es doch nicht
sein
das kannst du jetzt echt nicht sein okay
dann laufen wir hinterher
ich kann an den bei amazon so mein name
ist peter lustig bleibt du bleibst du
mal dahin mach du mal dein ding ich
dachte auf gar keinen fall den rücken zu
kehren weil er mich sofort absenken wird
er wieder okay jetzt mache ich mich auch
auf dem acker okay er kommt uns auch
nicht nach wir haben auch so wenig zeigt
hier bekomme ich sie gar kein kissen die
ganze zeit meine fresse nr games gerade
einfach mehr so schreibe games weiß
nicht ums ändern geht ihr wisst weil
energie eigentlich uns ändern weil es
zweifel games uns so weisen aber wir
können nicht so gut ändern weil wir
nicht so das equipment haben habe ich
gefühl
okay das ist auf jeden fall umgebracht
da unten hätte es nicht getrackt weil
das wasser ist gehen wir darunter haben
wir alternativen und skelett ok nach der
krise skelett gaal und liegt gut mit
doch gerne mit ja ja ja das haben wir
schon vier das ding auf die vier
fahrzeug da können wir dann auch nachher
unseren zug braden alter ich bin ein
heute habe ich aber echt glücklich jump
darüber und das aber so gerd schild mal
so ein kleines wasserbecken und da ist
ein kleiner amigo der gerne zeigen will
aber die wird nichts wirklich halten
wollen und deswegen natürlich sind heute
wieder känguru so habe ich gefühlt ja
schade den habe ich noch ganz gut hits
gegeben aber hat wohl nicht gereicht hat
wohl nicht gereicht dann gehen einfach
mal kurz in der runde ko sg kropp
boxster weile games für die ganzen kopf
selber unter euch so da sind wir wieder
und zwar wie gamestar in münchen da habe
ich mich entschieden hätten dranzuhängen
okay geht reaktor ist auf jeden fall mal
kein schwert drin
das ist schlechter ist schon mal ein
bisschen mehr erschwert drin war bitte
richtig anziehen
danke das ist dass es fucking selten als
ich werde selten da ist das glück uns
auf jeden fall holt sollte ich nehme es
mit warm sehr gut glück all das schöne
ist schwer jetzt muss auch was draus
machen läuft ja bei uns ja und da
willkommen in quick fire games ak
abstaubt games ak
wir laufen die zu zweit hinterher und
greifen uns nicht an games oder
natürlich daran
ich weiß es nicht
da sind jetzt immer noch welche der
folgt mir auch nach hinten weg vor mir
ja alle bald auf mich viel spaß
danke vielleicht könnt ihr euch gerne
öfter gegenseitig reagan
irgendwie hab ich das gefühl die leute
kämpfen nicht so wirklich gegeneinander
oder nicht soll der bogen hat und dann
auch noch getroffen
der hat noch gesessen als der entfernung
no look und das ziel zu sehen
okay er versteckt sich da will der muss
auch sterbende oder
dass wir als ganz so riskante sprünge
bleiben erst mal herum ziehen wir das
hier an leute einmal in eisenstadt meine
fresse ich hatte eigentlich hat noch nie
in eisenstadt den kriegsfall ganz aus
der kiste gezogen da muss ich erst mal
ein bisschen anstrengender kann ich sein
dahinter kommen name drauf zeigen wo der
hammer hängt im kollegen
und der hammer hängt hier hallo zack weg
mit dir
der nächste ist wahrscheinlich eher da
unten
ja denn auch eisen schwert bogen ein
schwert aber jetzt auch ziemlich lola so
wie es aussieht dann oft auch weg
der war nicht so läuft okay na gut die
leute auf jeden fall demnächst was noch
zum abschluss zunächst wie gesagt feiern
wir geburtstag max kommt mich besuchen
und dabei wahrscheinlich ein paar videos
machen oder so möchte man die
laufflächen geburtstags blog wenn ihr
rockt offen geburtstags video dann lasst
einfach mal leichter und schreibt mir
die kommentare hier fallen die
kommentare und dann sehen wir uns
natürlich beim nächsten video wieder
haut rein macht und